two weeks and three days away from the
start of the regular season
one week removed from the nfl announcing
an outcome in the antonio brown helmet
dispute and it feels like we're still no
closer to knowing what is going on with
antonio brown deja vu all over again for
the raiders in a b yes i mean it's just
the gift that keeps on giving i mean it
really is it's unbelievable that we're
still here talking about it i was
shocked to find out about the loophole
as far as the helmet rule that he had
skirted around as far as the 10-year
with this shut-air helmet
but either way the nfl closed that
loophole they've had enough and and
really i kind of was expecting this i
mean i didn't think they were just going
to let somebody go out there in a helmet
that they didn't approve and didn't pass
you know the proper testing and just
go ahead
yeah but that's where this starts to get
off the rails right right because they
never banned the helmet they never
banned the shut air advantage until
antonio brown realized that there's a
loophole here hey you tell me i can't
wear a helmet that's more than 10 years
old i'll go find
the same model that's less than 10 years
old and the problem is as of last monday
night he was under the impression based
on communications with the raiders who
supposedly had communicated with the
league that this is an acceptable
alternative because of the 11 helmet
models that were banned by the nfl
in 2018 and guys like tom brady had a
one year grace period to figure out
which helmet they're going to transition
to the shut air advantage wasn't one of
them okay so let's go this way okay go
ahead sorry sorry go ahead no go ahead i
was gonna say so to you i mean it just
looks like just from the outside looking
in does it not just look like the nfl
kind of overlooked this they figured
they didn't have to ban a helmet that
was that was made you know or got
stopped being produced in 2011
is it simply just that that the nfl kind
of just
overlooked this because they didn't
think they had to put it on there
because it's been so long since it's
been in production
i think the one angle to all of this
that the nfl is not going to highlight
is that they
kind of blew it by not testing the shut
air advantage
apparently because not a lot of players
right were wearing the shut air
advantage but still
one of the highest profile players in
the league the guy who was on the cover
of the madden game last year
was wearing the shut air advantage while
on the cover of the madden game last
year so somebody blew it here right yeah
somebody who should have recognized this
is a helmet that should have been tested
when they had their 11 band models this
should have been banned model number 12
they blew it yeah and they expedited it
last week once antonio brown realized i
got a loophole here yeah because if i
can find one of these things that's less
than 10 years old i can wear it again
this at best it's very bad communication
because as of monday night brown
believed based on communications with
the raiders who apparently were in
communication with the league that this
was acceptable and at some point once it
looked like antonio brown had found a
solution and it found multiple helmets
that were the shut air advantage model
that were less than 10 years old
he's gonna win
until he's not and that's when they
expedited the testing and chris here's
the thing that i have a problem with
okay and this is this is to me
what could provide the basis for a much
stronger grievance than the last one
that antonio brown filed because that
first grievance was embarrassingly weak
and never should have been pursued this
time around what he should say is look
all these other guys got a year once you
identified their helmet as being banned
you allowed them for a year to wear in
games and practices a helmet that you
decided was insufficient for nfl players
to wear why don't i get my year they all
got their year right you're not giving
me my year and that's why i think that
if he wanted to do it and i think he may
he's got a much stronger grievance this
time around than he did last time well
it is interesting it's a good point you
bring up uh the only thing i'd say there
is is he the only player that's that was
wearing that shut air advantage out of
the 32 players that we knew that had to
change their helmet this year i'm just i
don't know no no no no okay no no the
shutter advantage wasn't bad chris
that's what people are losing sight on i
know but i was not one of the eleven
months one of the 32 guys that's only
one wearing it maybe that's how it gets
overlooked as far as not being tested
again i i don't know i'm just throwing
out there no
but but the guys who were wearing the
helmets last year that had been banned
that their helmets had been banned they
knew i got one year to come up with
something else last year tom brady was
in and out of that new helmet all the
time he tried out for a game he'd go
back to the old one the old one that has
been banned by the league he still kept
wearing it because he was taking full
advantage of that one year grace period
yes right antonio brown's not getting a
full football season to get used to a
new helmet tom brady did aaron rodgers
did others did and that would be the
basis for a potentially persuasive
grievance before we run out of time in
this segment
there's some comments from people other
than us that we need to share with you
because the raiders have kind of drawn
the line in the sand with antonio brown
they don't believe there's anything else
that needs to be done at this point
other than picking a new helmet and
showing up for work here's what general
manager mike mayok had to say sunday on
behalf of the organization and it sends
a very loud and clear message to antonio
brown
a b is not here today right right so
here's the bottom line he's upset about
the helmet issue
we have supported that we appreciate
that
okay but we've at this point we've
pretty much exhausted all avenues of
relief
so from our perspective
it's time for him to be all in we're all
out
okay so we're hoping he's back soon we
got 89 guys busting their tails we are
really excited about where this
franchise is going and we hope a b is
going to be a big part of it starting
week one against denver
end of story
no question
a little good cup bad cop there in
oakland because john gruden's never
making that statement is he chris no
he's not but i think that he gives the
green light for that statement to be
made been and i think that's very
telling that that's where we're at it's
it's finally done of like oh hey gosh we
love you you're our new toy it's okay
we've had enough it's business and i'm
sure john gruden when things kind of
went awry yesterday and they realized
that he was not in the building he had
had enough too and finally gave mike
maya the green light to go ahead and say
a public statement like that
and the way that mayor characterized it
at this point there's nothing more that
can be done we've exhausted all avenues
there are no further options it's grab
an approved helmet and show up for work
or get out that's basically the message
and if he gets out he gives up 30
million dollars i can't imagine him not
doing it if it ever comes to that but
according to drew rosenhaus who
represents antonio brown and this is
from last night on wsvn in miami drew
rosenhaus doesn't seem to believe that
all options have been exhausted here's
what rosenhaus had to say
we've worked very closely
with the raiders and we will continue to
work very closely with the raiders i'm
not sure that we agree that we've
exhausted all the options as
mike mayok said
but there's no doubt it's still an
ongoing process
we are trying to work with the team and
the league and the union to come up with
the solution we haven't figured out yet
to say that a b is upset about the
decision
to not let him wear his helmet is
accurate but we're still processing it
and figuring it out i wouldn't make too
much about him not being there today as
much as we're still trying to come up
with the solution that works
okay that was drew rosenhaus again and
and he disagrees with mike mayok yeah
there's he thinks there's something more
that can be done all right what's the
bottom line is when they're making when
you're a 30 million guaranteed you can't
not show up for work just because the
nfl told you not to wear a helmet that's
the first thing right i mean enough is
enough like i mean holy cow nobody in
football could get away with this would
do this nothing it's it's it's it's
reckless it's bad leadership it's
everything he's not he's becoming a
problem in in oakland already and that's
why mike miak had to make that comment
second of all um yeah i mean okay maybe
what what's the other avenue they could
exhaust maybe he gets a one-year
exemption like you're saying but as big
as player safety is right now in the nfl
and the fact that all the attention is
on this right now i just have a hard
time than thinking that the nfl is going
to bow down to antonio brown and go well
hey this helmet that didn't pass any of
our tests we're just going to let you
wear it i just i don't see it going that
way they're going to draw a hard line in
the sand here it's going to be concrete
line actually and i don't i just can't
imagine it happening
chris but here's the thing yeah last
year yeah there were 11 helmet models
that were deemed to be unfit by the nfl
right and they allowed players like tom
brady to continue to wear them so that
logic can easily be twisted back around
on the nfl you've already done it don't
don't tell me that this is an age of of
maximum sensitivity to safety when you
let guys last year continue to wear
helmets that you deem to be unsafe for
use you let them wear them so how does
antonio brown not get the same courtesy
when you decide to rush to testing a
helmet model that you failed to test
when you came up with yours and this off
season that he had to wear a new helmet
and he had a loophole and they're not
going to happen right he knew that he
had to get a replacement for his helmet
that was more than 10 years old whatever
helmet model it is after 10 years noxian
he didn't know the 10 years old thing
until
last week he had no idea so brain should
be wrapped around i need another helmet
no no no no right but chris you're
losing sight this is why so many people
are confused you're confused by it all
due respect i'm not it's not about a
helmet it's not about a helmet being
more than 10 years old at this point any
helmet that is more than 10 years old
can't be worn it's about the model
itself the nfl never said hey look
here's the shut air advantage let's put
this through our testing and let's
decide whether or not this is a helmet
that players can wear they did it last
week only after antonio brown identified
a loophole that would have allowed him
to win see i feel like at a certain
level this comes down to the nfl not
wanting to let antonio brown win they
don't want the perception the appearance
that he fought the law and the law lost
i feel like that's a big part of this
why else would they not give him a
one-year grace period when a year ago
tom brady wore throughout the season a
helmet that the nfl had determined to be
unsafe why did they give those guys a
grace period and why are they not giving
it to antonio brown and i'll tell you
what if i'm antonio brown if i'm someone
advising him i'm saying here's your
grievance last week's grievance was an
embarrassment this week's grievance is
viable well again i understand what
you're saying and i understand exactly
what's going on i also understand that
the nfl is king here okay and they're
not going to let anybody just do they
messed up obviously they i yes they
messed up by not putting this on their
band helmet list either way antonio
brown went into just before last week
knowing that he was going to have to
change his helmet and he didn't like it
all so he can't be that shocked by this
recent development so yes i understand
it's not quite exactly as fair as tom
brady or aaron rodgers got it and
everything else but he was very aware
that the last year was going to be his
last year of wearing that helmet into
this that specific training that's
specific right okay so he he shouldn't
be that shocked he went through warm-ups
wearing the other helmet he's making
30 million dollars guaranteed i'd like
to think he's talented enough and mature
enough at this point to catch passes in
his new helmet and move on with life for
a team that's paying them all this money
and brought him in there for a second
you know breath of fresh air in his
career and and there are investing in
him and want him to be the leader of the
team and that's all i'm saying i
understand your points your points are
real too i'm not trying to
i know you're turning 39 soon but you're
still a little too young to go with the
get off my lawn routine i mean here's
the bottom line if he had quietly found
a new shut air advantage that was less
than 10 years old and gotten that thing
re-certified which it was the helmet has
been recertified by noxie it wouldn't
have been an issue we wouldn't know
about any of this until the specific
helmet he wants to wear is more than 10
years old that's what if he had gotten a
helmet in 2010
a shutter advantage then made the year
that he joined the nfl this wouldn't be
an issue until next year because it
would still be less than 10 years old
because the nfl didn't include initially
the shutter advantage on that list of
banned helm
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports